cool simple as ice yeah just are doing
oh yeah that's the other question are we
able to like because obviously I would
have thought cuz it mean to Geordie just
move about and compressive is that going
to be a problem yeah
rollin right mate
finally finally being a whale yep you've
taken a [__] ton of time off of youtube
this year you're being hidden away
nobody knows what the hell you've been
doing this is more secretive than most
professional boxers training camps ever
what's it being like they just switch
off and be not a youtuber anymore
just a boxer well I mean like mmm for me
that firstly the whole thing of me like
going away and like why I'm doing that
it's not it's not for any other reason
bar like I've just been focusing so I
mean I think that's what it comes down
to though I've just been doing what I
need to do limiting all the distractions
all the extra things just so I can just
focus and get to only to be what's it
being like I mean I've been tested in
every way that's what it's been night
like I'm gonna talk about mentally
physically emotionally every single way
I've had a challenge I mean push to my
absolute limit
I remember the video you did after our
last podcast we are sort of Satya you
just looked like you're falling in
you're not interested your heart isn't
in it anymore and it was clear you did
that video you had the ghost thing
coming out you were you were in a
transitional phase you were searching
for something that's what you were so I
literally said those words who I'm
looking for something to actually
challenge me yeah you know and when this
came along right it's opportunity us I
sort of had the vision of where this
could go
like the whole boxing thing I'm going
against JJ this is it you know and that
is why I have completely dedicated and
committed to doing everything I can to
be prepared because this is this is the
challenge this is what can really put
tell me to that next level what do you
mean by next next level of what as a as
an entertainer as what what do you want
No
so why next say one mean like so I've
had a change of like YouTube making
videos kind of build the audience kind
of you know make good videos and I've
faced up to that challenge and I've I
feel like I've done a good job when I
say next level I mean more like a
different level like something that can
show a different side to me that I
wasn't able to express through YouTube
or at least inside yes is about you as a
person growing yeah not about you know
achieving money and all of us here
that's the thing with this this has been
an absolute challenge of what I am about
as a person when I talk about when I say
dedicate when I say commit I mean not
just when I'm feeling good you know and
that's I feel like with YouTube I was
sort of getting to that point where I
was sort of I feel do I feel good do I
feel not good doing this is it because
of YouTube is it because I mean I wasn't
I was kind of confused and this has
really cut it out simple as no matter
what I feel like I've got to go to work
you've never heard that for a long time
because I do too much it's a [__]
luxury we can get up and not get up and
me and you both will talk about mental
health and the past and sort of some
days you don't necessarily feel like it
in this scenario you know if you don't
get up and the other guy does get up
it's gonna be bad news for you down the
road so almost that drives you if forces
you cannot abandon them on and for a
different reason
what does it being like for you to know
that yeah I mean to be honest like when
I say it's like this whole situation as
a whole has been one of the great well
probably the thing that I needed at this
point in my life like I actually mean it
because I was going a bit like when I
say off the rails
I mean like not knowing where I was
going not knowing what I wanted and with
this with that like regimented lifestyle
of getting up having to face whatever
challenge is that day and having to
because if not I'm gonna lose huh you
know it's been it's been the best thing
that's happened to me in a long time I
remember the last podcast you talked
about integrity yeah and I can say that
so [__] important here moving forward
you know you're talking about how this
has tested you what where do you feel
like it's tested you the most as a
person so as a person was there a moment
where you look back to your train and
company you can describe the mean now
where you say there was this day and I
remember this day stacks out more than
any other or a period of time where it
was grueling that's the thing
realistically I mean if we fully break
it down every single day there is
honestly something new and that's no
exaggeration there is something new that
is testing me to a point that really
city has not been pushed that far before
as a more overall with a split it into
like physical mental like physically
obviously you know I've done
weightlifting I've done sport before but
we have trained to an absolute elite
level like so my maximum potential with
this so I've obviously had to face the
knee injury in amongst that physical
stuff and yeah like that is what it is
obviously the physical side has not in
my opinion for me being as testing as
I'd say the mental side and that was
obviously the question is well are gonna
be able to take it emotion on this a lot
gonna be able to handle it yeah and when
I say that that has been the most
testing that's because that is what I've
had to overcome and level up because a
lot my physical was here and my mentor
was here obviously in order to get them
both up to top I'm gonna have to do more
work mentally generally and I feel like
I have faced faced a lot and what I've
had what I've dealt with through the
lows through the Downs through honestly
the lowest and I have felt the lowest
I've ever felt in my life during this
experience and overcoming that that is
what that is where I'm getting my
confidence from that is where because I
have proven to myself on a daily basis
what I'm about and I'm not chatting [__]
because I prove it
I'm proud me accent really [__] good
I think I wanted that for you yeah
coming into this and I know there will
it be a moment where you've doubted
yourself and it seems like you've come
through that on the other side sparring
sessions things like that how have you
found learning the skill of box and have
you fallen in love with it or is it
something that was a necessary evil to
get you where you wanted to be yeah so
obviously at first like I mean you saw
it in the field video I it wasn't
exactly looking a natural and natural
ability that I just had I've had to I've
had to do more than anything yet the
boxing you know so I from the fitness
aside from all of that the Box in it's
tedious it's very repetitively it's not
like overly complex end of the day
you've got a left hand your right hand
and it's how you throw them and and it's
just been a lot of that getting a
technique as spot-on as I can like I say
just very tedious very repetitive but I
think it's that that is as well build
your mind the fact that no matter how
tedious it is how grueling or whatever
you do it and it's it's that it's that
sense of professionalism that I feel
like I've really grown into along this
journey that no matter what you get the
job done
self-esteem is something I'm picking up
from you that I hadn't seen in a while
like you know I think when you feel like
you're floundering or you're not
fulfilling your potential we all feel
like well let my selves down yet and now
the line I'm sitting talking and I was
like I can tell you've grown up a photo
and since the last time was funny
because it's like a boy to a man
yeah I swear to God the difference is
unbelievable and I can tell all those
rounds and testing yourself now you know
who you are and that's you've really
found out who you are in this until you
see yourself differently now how did the
people closest around you see you after
going through illnesses they're kind of
going through with you and also I can
imagine some of them are
but oh god he's getting in the friggin
boxing ring yeah yeah obviously like the
first person who comes to mind is my mum
yeah right from the beginning
the thought of obviously robust like
just the violence she wasn't too keen on
yep but saying that she could not have
been any more supportive like honestly
my whole family everyone close to me I
think they know how much it means to me
and they have literally done everything
they came at my mum she makes me at
dinner every night not honestly she
brings it round night it's so sweet but
she that that's what she does it cuz
it's like she feels like that's her
condo to the process and it helps man I
come in at like 9 o'clock from training
at night and you know it's it's unreal
to just have a dinner there ready to go
my sister like she's always there she's
like a best mate to me you know we're
going on dog Ward's shoe like she knows
me inside out so I can recommend thought
to her on a level of have any of them
company you and said I'm scared of
anything happening to you how did that
make you feel and who what what happened
so the thing is right at the beginning
when I myself can't see like I've never
done this before never done boxing
before so I don't know how I'm meant to
feel when I'm ready or how I'm going to
feel when I'm you know at the end of
camp
so I'd say at the beginning its kind of
more difficult when I say like convince
him I'm gonna be able to do this it's
sort of just like reinstall a bit of
like they're your to them you're their
baby yeah yeah I mean yeah so I mean I
just at the beginning I was just saying
like look you know me you know how
dedicate when I'm passionate about
something I'm obsessed and I do
everything I can to do you know like do
I need to do to get to learning to be
and realistically throughout that has
been that sort of idea has been my
philosophy and now I can I have sort of
the footage I have the stuff that we
filmed along the way to be like mom look
well I can do it you know think honestly
like more things like that and they've
seen
me grow they've seen me go over and I
think that's what's giving them more
confidence that obsession if something I
have reminded people of when everyone's
saying JJ is bigger you know he's taller
etc and I'm like you know there's not
longer prepare for this fight and
whoever in my opinion can be obsessed
and can just literally focus on this and
only this for that time is going to have
an advantage when you when you're coming
into this fight is is that part of what
you're one of your weapons would you see
in this that's the thing the one thing
at the beginning I said is I want I
don't want there to be anything that
happens on that night that I am not
prepared for right that comes as a
surprise and I'll see what comes with
that it is by doing a [__] ton I mean so
that that belief that I have when I
stand there ready to go and walk out to
that ring I can stand and go knows no
there is nothing more I could have done
to prepare myself for this moment that
is what I think will give me confidence
more than anything whereas if you're
standing there like are maybe if I when
I was doing the New Year's Eve party at
this point moment I could have been
training or when you know when I was
traveling to Japan I could have been
training you know probably you know that
that's that's that are you taking a
little bit of confidence from the fact
that you feel you're you're putting the
work in and then you'll see and juju
going on these holidays or whatever he's
doing that's the thing not I try not to
you know yeah okay the facts are he's
doing what he's doing but regardless
whether ease [__] whether he's the
second comment of Anthony Joshua right
I'm gonna do my thing and that's it I'm
not going to take confidence from his
weaknesses join me I'm going to take
conference from my strengths so I mean
and that's it's that that I want to sort
of like focus on rather than what he's
doing he may be going and doing all
these things and that's what works for
him
maybe not doesn't wouldn't that wouldn't
work for me I wanted my life to be as
simple as possible when you know I'm
preparing some of this because then
whatever happens I guess you're feeling
like you
know you'll have left everything in the
ring and given your hundred-percent and
you're not going to question yourself as
did I do my best
yeah I was good attitude to hover mitt
what do you think looking back on this
training come has been your favorite
part of it is there a bit that you've
enjoyed the most enjoyed and we've all
seen some of the spotting pictures yeah
yeah man I've just we kind of touched on
it but I've just enjoyed when we say
like finding myself sort of thing of
finding what I'm about and I think that
because of how for so long how I was
feeling the opposite so now at the end
of this sort of journey feel that like
reinstalled I'd say that's that's what
I'm going to take away most from this
fight on the flip side is there anything
that you look back on it and think
[__] hell I never want to do that I
kept getting of a knee injury for sure
now I mean I do you know when you're
doing the spine for example yeah this is
new some people are not Ricky Gervais
did a charity boxer much very different
than this obviously but he said when he
first went in the idea of hitting
someone just didn't feel right because
I've never he's never done it before
that I'm not a violent man and it took
him a while to get used to that is that
something that you found easy or hard
and yeah now throwing punches something
I've never really thrown punches are
being met in too many fights before but
that throwing punches wasn't really the
issue that's the thing like I don't view
it as arm throwing not out of because I
always say in like from that Ricky Ricky
Gervais is common that he's relating it
to like emotion like the idea of hurting
someone with like bad intent and it's
like that whole emotional side of it I
recognized very early as I like you
don't want to include emotion too much
around this it's I'm doing the action
because I'm to like to win
I don't really see it as you see it
moves the spot then yeah then a fight
fight because do you feel like if you go
in there and be hothead well ah yeah
you'll leave yourself but really see the
first person to lose their head loses I
think that's that's basically it if you
can't handle yourself you can't like no
matter what happens to you like say
getting beat down if you lose your head
you know like say Joshua Klitschko if
when Joshua got hit down first overtime
hit down he could have lost his head and
bang gone but the fact that he
controlled his emotion and went forward
and did what he did he wins and that's a
difference
you have mentioned Joshua you spoke
about the Conor McGregor documentary
yeah and and how you've drawn from these
professional fighters is there anyone
who stands out who you've watched more
than anyone else and you think oh that
guy
he's one person I really admire and I've
taken a lot from him Mike Tyson Mike
Tyson real purely because more than
anything his explosiveness and not only
that his cold-bloodedness like the way
he liked not necessary in the later
stages of his trying yeah when he was
getting at like not when he's getting on
Malfi like ah [__] you or whatever not
that just where he'd get he go to the
ring
no [__] get the job done and then he
picks up his opponent and says like good
much goes home flights in it's no
[__] it's good doing what he needs
to do and and winning should I mean and
that's that I take a lot of inspiration
from that you walk in the gym first day
especially the YouTuber
yeah that's real form up a bit how did
they see you then
now this is a thing obviously you know
yeah they were I they obviously didn't
say this but obviously you get a little
bit of a sense of like you know what's
he doing up in pretty boy I will see
girl surely he loves his face too much
to learn this light is he for real sort
of thing by the same time you sense that
that sense of respect where they
realized that you know you're not
invincible and who's to say that I'm not
going to go in there and you know
give them some difficulty so there's
that there is that balance obviously do
you think you've won their respective
overtime
I believe so yeah I believe so I don't
know I think we'll anything it's the
fact that whenever whenever they go
there I'm there like when it like I
think that's the sort of they realize
what I'm putting into this after this is
all said and done yeah
will you carry on boxing as in even just
as a hobby yeah I think you'll know I
think so purely because it's been well
what I've gained and learned from this
experience
I honestly think through keeping on with
it even if it is just for fun I think
I'll it will remind me of these values
I've learned and I will continue to be
able to take them into the real world
so yeah do you think a lot of your
subscribers I know they're gonna be
sitting there wondering because you're
gonna sort of being away for so long
yeah seeing the little interview you did
with John Cena but there was not a lot
on the channel you just sort of took a
massive break they're gonna be singing
Izzy back for good
is he gonna do are we gonna get the old
Joella back which I don't think we are
to be honest with you looking at you now
but are we gonna get a new job Ella who
is back my new tube regularly yet or
have you not decided anything like yet
so that's the thing we're obviously my
mind has been entirely just on this
fight and I haven't really made a plan
of exactly what I'm gonna do regarding
YouTube just naturally where I have been
dedicating that hasn't been another time
to sort of really think about that but
afterwards yeah think about it yeah like
definitely that's the thing I'm not I
don't want it to come across like I'm
saying I am you know from what I've said
before with you and stuff that are I'm
done with YouTube I never want to do
that like I say I want to be
professional with it and do whatever is
best for me and I know that sounds very
general in a bit cliche but I think
simply looking it like that looking at
it like that and not looking or what
what should i do that's
pop in or what's gonna do well because I
if I believe in myself and I believe
whatever I do and truly become obsessed
and passionate about will turn out good
and that's what it matters
one of the things that is in keeping
with this whole subjective spot on
YouTube is you and JJ together I've got
the responsibility to and we've seen a
lot of youtubers who have let us down
lately and you know it's like one
YouTube I just something dumb we all
look like idiots yeah we're kind of
lying on the Perry you are like hold the
good start that you know make us look
good do you feel that do you feel like
you've got responsibilities of the rest
of the community or is that not even
mentor in your head yeah now of course I
mean it is essentially we are
representing YouTube here and because
mainstream are gonna be laughing yeah
yeah before you get in the ring yeah
they're all gonna sort of hope
yeah this is a joke yeah and I of course
but that's the thing and obviously when
you look back at their press conference
that kind of falls into what the
mainstream one are we're out of control
we have no have no morals we're just
coming out of all this stuff and
certainly the way I'm going to conduct
myself like I say I want to be
professional I want to be respectful
like I say I have not got any any bad
intentions of trying to do any dirty on
JJ I just want to go there demonstrate
what I'm about and what I've done and
how I've grown and that's that still law
as much as you're speaking
professionally yeah you're still human
yeah yeah yeah I'm JJ appear and the
tricky light he can be my try and white
as you up yeah because everyone's sort
of talked about the mental you know
Joella freezes and whatever are you
prepared for that are you have you got a
sort of mind state where you're like
whatever he does I'm just gonna soar now
and that's okay I'm not guys I'm not
gonna obviously just sit there and go
I'd I can't hear you JJ that you know I
mean it's like it's not gonna be so like
that it's more just gonna be look focus
on what's important like right now we
can do all the talking he can say all
these things but it doesn't actually
like the
time that is done sort of thing yeah
what surprised me about you in the past
I'm thinking that the Jamie Carragher
moment is be honest for you I know it's
not your most favorite YouTube moment
but one thing that I took away from that
as an alder like that you it's for me
there's no fear in this kid at all at
that point you hadn't be at all the
boxing training do you feel a bit more
of the fear than you used to or is it
healthy or is it manageable or what is
your sort of relationship with the fear
of cording to a fight with someone cuz I
remember that day I was looking at you
and there was just nobody home you were
like I'll fight them I don't care you
know I mean yeah I mean look the thing
is I take it back to what I said at the
beginning regarding getting in there and
being pushed to your absolute limit now
you can put on or not when I say put on
you can believe you know you've got what
it takes and all that but in other day I
eventually came against someone who did
get the better of me
and kick the [__] out of me honestly and
that I'd say more than anything that's
what can install the fear of like okay
now I know it no now I know it it feels
like to you know take it did you kind of
is that with a lot of this confidence is
coming from though as well as and I'm
still here and that's what I'm saying
that's that's Lee she was about say it's
the fact of like okay yeah I have to
fear you can will you you know you
naturally get that emotion of [__] I
don't want to get that again and it's
how you deal with that do you just run
away and go now that's it or do you face
it and through facing it and overcoming
it and overcoming multiple challenges a
like a day like I've said that's what
gives me the confidence it's not just an
ego thing I'm better than jjr I'm really
thinking about JJ it's the fact of that
I've literally that on a daily basis now
for months proving to myself what I'm
actually about that's where the
confidence comes from YouTube is a
[__] bubble at the end of the day me
and once you're in it it's sort of
nothing else sort of matters yeah and I
know you were like a dick as we all have
been
but now you totally removed yourself
from that how was your perspective
change now looking at from a boxers
perspective well that's the thing
as good as obviously like the whole
YouTube world is and it is it can be
really fun and rewarding I do agree that
it it doesn't give a true reflection of
reality like I have learnt through doing
something that is very very real
I think definitely going forward now
it's gonna give me a different
perspective I think saying that though
when I talk about like how I've learned
through this experience like no matter
what doing what you need to do in
getting the job done I feel with YouTube
it can you can still you know coast
along without actually getting a job
done and I think that is where I was
maybe going wrong before like you're
still you know you can still get views
you can still get all that without
actually putting the work in
and I think I was going bit wrong I was
like okay I'm getting these views I'm
doing all that but I don't feel like I'm
putting the work into my best of my
ability and getting that do not I mean
speaking of someone who who had a proper
job well I was doing 12-hour ideas
working offshore [__] the YouTube
I've come at the YouTube and I feel like
of them excel very fast compared to a
lot of people around me because I had a
work ethic yeah exactly and I'm looking
around and like I'm seeing a lot of
these lads who are tick and literally
putting 35% in but because the the game
they're playing is trending or the topic
they're talking about was trending
they're still getting the views but I
don't want to just tread and I don't
want to do it I want to put a hundred
percent in yeah so like you say I can
look myself around say given that yeah
yeah yeah and I feel like coming back to
YouTube if that's what's all for you
you're you're more like a working man
now because you put actually is that
work ethic yes that you know no matter
what you've got that worth it work ethic
about you and definitely that more than
anything is what I've I feel
been stored into myself now and yeah my
life I look back on my clock that before
yeah but yeah but until you have to get
up yeah it's in YouTube people it's a
luxury it's a luxury lifestyle - I get
up and do a video a day or not yeah yeah
whereas the only thing that would have
ever have gotten your bed to the point
of where you have to is I'm gonna fight
them for it to be a thousand people how
does that how does the crowd at all of
that
you train in and it's just you and in a
culture miss bar important and all of
that all of a sudden and I know you've
been in front of crowds before you song
and doing all sorts of performances now
you're taking punches in front of people
yeah do you think you're just gonna zone
that out or are you gonna be aware
that's the thing obviously we're not
gonna know entire entirely for sure
until we do it like I'm not gonna say I
mean like yeah it's fine it's fine
but end of the day all I know is that I
have how I've prepared in the ring and
in a gym I take when I say comfort it's
like the opposite of comfortable but
when I say take comfort I mean being in
that ring is a uncomfortable in the ring
so the people are there but whether
they're not there when I'm in the ring
and I'm doing my thing
that's all I'm focused on and I think
that literally being able to take that
directly into this scenario is a it's
only come from doing it repetitively
doing it on a daily basis look not
martial arts in general it's like you
have to train your brain to react to
certain ways but in chaos yeah you still
react in a comfortable way exactly and
that's what you're you're calm in the
chaos now is that how it feels yeah yeah
before all of this happened you were
famous for your disk or muscles you know
you you're training to look good now
it's functional how is that being for
you in terms of a totally different type
of training Oh me right I don't begin
obviously I thought yeah I've got a bit
straight I've got a bit of fitness it's
a completely different ballgame I it's
completely different and
obviously now you know just some people
could look and go okay yeah your arm
still looks the same but my arm would do
that like 20 times before literally with
no way and be burning so it's all about
like you said functional functional
exercise and functional movements not
about what you look like or you know if
you've got the six-pack or what
everyone's how are those ABS gonna be
used because before okay I had the
six-pack I was doing an exercise that
didn't actually require core strength
yeah do you not I mean yeah even if it
may look similar on the outside so yeah
that's been that's been massive almost
changing like normally you can take an
average person and make them one thing I
have to almost reverse and then move on
to because you've been built for
explosive yeah yeah and second strength
exactly which is weight training you
you're on it you're holding your breath
practically whereas now it's it's not
anaerobic it's a robic strength yeah
because you've got to be explosive
you've got always do anaerobic behaviors
but whilst maintaining I breathe yeah
and not burning out and being able to
last around so the wrong thing that's
gonna be a six-run fire yep six
three-minute rounds how many hours a day
is normal for you to spend in the gym
um so eight hours [__] hell yeah it's
basically an it's basically my full-time
job and that's why I obviously I haven't
been doing anything else
obviously it's split into strength and
conditioning training boxing specific
training physio rehab for them you must
be eating so much to manage all of this
5,000 calories a day
Wow and what that's not like you though
I mean I'm not I'm that guy yeah like
you you always were like on a diet
hardly at all it's been hot the training
your body mate absorbed that much so
yeah I'd say honestly like one of the
hardest thing has been eating you know
had on a daily basis force-feed like
that is just how it is getting the
calories in or else I can't I can't
train because I
covering yeah if you're not I mean I
just don't have that energy and I felt
that because at the beginning I tried to
almost yet because I kind of wanted to
maintain the more ripped fizzy fizzy can
really low percentage of body fat you
have said that like in order to do what
I need to do I'm gonna have to just eat
and yeah like it is what it is but like
I say through whatever it takes
you've always had a really open
relationship with your subscribers yeah
I think that's what made you different
from a lot of people this how you cried
in front of them you've left you've done
everything yet how do you think that
they are going to see you after this
fight when they see the documentary and
everything that's gone into what you've
been through
well a me and like going into this in
this whole process I really wanted to
represent the fact of you know it's not
about where you're from what you know or
even what you're doing if you really are
passionate and obsessed with it and put
in the work then you you can achieve and
I think that's how my viewers will be
able to like I've spoken about along
those sort of lines like before but I
think this will really like hopefully
show you know put it into action and
demonstrate that that what I'm saying is
you know legit and and I really do mean
what I say you know talking about ksi
and everything that's gone on between
you and him in the past
being it sort of comfort almost full
circle
he sort of discovered you and then you
became mates and then obviously a
falling-out up and other friends have
been involved in all of this well right
about to get into the ring with each
other here what are your thoughts and
feelings towards him personally no there
is absolutely nothing I feel towards him
it's not personal I don't hate ksi I
would just what are we standing I'll
just be ready focused to do the job that
I need to do it won't be how much
hey it won't be how much I want to hurt
him and you know do him dirty or
whatever
no like and that's that's what I'm
saying completely detaching emotion away
from this situation
you and him seem to be talking very
differently I watched a podcast that
they did the Seidman recently and he I
was surprised at how confident he was he
he was he was talking as if it was going
to be easy and I know a lot of people
want to see in that what does it make
you feel when he says I mean I know that
this is going up and I bet any money
this is going to be a walk in the park
really is writing you off realize that
he may he could have just read that from
an absolute boxing cliche like he's just
whipped out everyone out of a book oh
I've already won
oh there's no chance like it's just you
know I mean anyway you know I mean it's
that obvious stuff to say go into a
boxing fight really and I'm realizing
now I'm obviously I'm no expert but that
the sort of stuff that you'd come out
with if you don't really know too much
about boxing jamming or what it's about
he's saying he's taller bigger stronger
richer advantage things of that nature
or do you think about the physical
advantages that people say he's got over
you as a thing as an advantage and
disadvantage to everything and say Tyson
smaller firing most of his most of his
fights obviously is Tyson but still you
know he ended up using with his style
using that to his own advantage
where is yeah I mean he's taller and
he's well he was a lot heavier and he's
obviously lost a lot of weight so I
don't know if there's gonna be too much
in that now he says I think you said he
was about 84 85 kilograms stomach
long-nosed like what are you gonna be
about 82 83 or other than sort of size
so there shouldn't be too much
difference actually yeah shouldn't be
too much that's a big night as well
obviously I'm training with all kinds of
guys like heavier taller smaller fast a
lot bigger stronger every sort of kind
of guy I'm trying to I'm trying to make
sure I'm prepared for one of the things
you said when you when I came in as you
were like how much ooh you win you can I
bet you could hurt someone
so you now all very aware of how hard a
punch feel yeah
how's there be in a few moments where
you taking a right could dig and hold
yourself
[__] this what am i doing of course mate
like the first-ever sparring session I
did you saw the absolute levels you know
you can have all the desire in the world
to win obviously at that point I hadn't
learnt the skills put in the work to
learn the skills so it gets shown up and
you feel it and I felt like a [__] mate
I'm not not no joke I felt like I might
just full of [__] is this is this for me
like really and when obviously I spoke
about that with my coaches and stuff
it's like use this as motivation to get
to where you need to be like tape
don't try and block out how you feel
right now really take in how you feel
right now and embrace it and use it to
your advantage you never want to feel
that we were gonna and how was your
called child you it not obviously in
just a boxing sense we know he's a an
expert but in that mental journey as he
brought you along yeah yeah yeah so um
you've got two coaches something so
that's the thing I got three a strength
and conditioning coach max boxing
specific it's just Dan and Navia to sort
of a mixture of both but he is really
good at sort of the whole mental side of
things and he's really opened up my eyes
just as much just as much as I've learnt
myself obviously his third person point
of view and being out tonight you know
working me along alongside like I'm just
oh yeah I just feel like I've opened up
my brain in so many ways through working
with these guys and they've always
supported me as a thing I in every way
they've supported and helped me grow up
like no way would I we've been able to
do this mm-hmm all by myself
and if you had to look at the fight
without obviously giving away your game
plan anything like that if you are to
say the main reason I'm gonna win this
fight is what would be the end of that
sentence
I have absolutely dedicated committed
and put more work in than my opponent
[__] them got answer for me love it
after say whatever happens we'll lose
our job [__] over the moon with how
where things have gone for you
I could see you've grown so much as a
block it's [__] Mendel it's absolutely
mad for real and I just thought that I
don't really care if you when I lose to
be honest with you like whatever happens
I'd like you to win obviously but I'm
not I just want you to be happy with how
you did and walk the way being like and
I think you will all right I already
know you will
cuz I know there's no way you're gonna
go in there and let yourself down you
know I mean so yeah oh good oh good